I'm Howard Bragman and I'm an author of
the upcoming book where's my fifteen
minutes
there was a recent study by the
MacArthur Foundation and it was about
teens and internet usage and was talking
about there was really a lot of positive
effects and one of the things that they
mentioned which is really interesting is
it was teaching teenagers how to manage
their public image and for the first
time in history people not every person
but most people who aspire to something
a little greater aspire to go to the
next level have a public image be you a
doctor a lawyer a journalist an Indian
chief whatever you do you may have a
website you may have a Facebook page of
MySpace page you may be on Twitter you
may be in newsletters you may be the
president of the PTA but it's never been
easier to have a public image I know now
if you I teach college at university of
southern california and i hadn't talked
for a few years guess what every college
professor is written about online are
they a good professor do we like the
class is it easy you're a college
professor you're a public figure and
there's different levels of this we're
not all Brad and Angelina obviously but
whatever milieu we operate in we are
public figures and the rules hold the
same whether you're a college professor
whether you're a movie star if you don't
define yourself somebody else is going
to define you and you're probably not
going to be happy with the way they
define you so you better do it yourself
I think controlling a public image is
myth nowadays i think my book is very
prescriptive in terms of managing a
public image ultimately as I tell my
celebrities the best public image you're
going to have is by living a good clean
life and people recognize it if people
me or anyone else misbehave it's going
to get out there in the ether and
there's a level of transparency as I say
in my ten commandments of PR the truth
will come out and it will bite you in
the butt eventually so I think the myth
that we can't control anything is kind
of just that it's a myth but but the
truth is we can manage and we can make
it better and as you stated if we start
out early and we create our image from
whole cloth early on that's a lot easier
than creating an image excuse me that's
a lot easier than modifying an image
that's already been created of having to
change in image particularly a bad image
what micro thing is being known for a
very specific thing within a very
specific community I think the Obama
girl had micro Fame that grew into macro
fame she started out on YouTube one song
about one candidate and all of a sudden
she turned it into a brand I want to do
something by comparison if you remember
in the last election jibjab the
cartoonist the animators they've turned
that into a business they have taken
their concept and brought it and really
turned it into a business I don't think
Obama girl has turned it into a business
so they took what could have been micro
Fame and turn is something that was
quite macro but micro Fame really means
that you may be famous within a Facebook
group you may be famous on YouTube you
may be famous in your high school
wherever it is but that may be all you
need to if you're running for class
president you probably don't need to be
famous behind your high school at that
particular point in your life and
everybody has to start somewhere and we
all have to realize that what is our
base if you're the running for president
of your high school class well your base
is your classmates and that's where
you're going to start and so micro Fame
can grow but it can also just lie there
and that can be the end point
well it's not just screwing it up it's
getting out there too soon people want
to rush their image out there without
building the foundation my own nephew
was trying to launch a little shirt
company and he got a story he's at the
University of Georgia and he got a story
in the University of Georgia paper and
I'm like hey genius do you have a
website up yet and he's like no and I
said how are people going to find your
shirts you moron don't you think you
should have gotten your ducks in a row
before you started doing he goes well
people know us on campus it's like yeah
it's a campus of 40,000 I think not you
know and and people it people are too
eager to get the press without doing the
work that's required it's very rare that
somebody can do horrible damage there
unless they're a celebrity or a true
true public figure or a politician you
know but anybody has to learn you have
to do the preparatory steps to make it
last this is how you build a lasting
image this is how you turn publicity
into sales publicity in to change
publicity into dollars publicity into
whatever it is you're trying to do if
you say I want to clean up the river and
you've created a website that's called
River clean calm you can say you go to
my website and you see how you can help
that's going to motivate people if you
say I'm here to clean up the river and I
want people to help me and they go well
what what in the hell do i do too to do
this you may not be as strong and what
we really have to do is connect the dots
and that's something the internet does
really well probably better than
anything in our life
there's a process and again it's not a
blueprint a blueprint would mean
everybody does the same thing but it's a
process and differences are based on
what's in your heart which are capable
of authenticity is a huge thing out
there we have great BS detectors out in
this world if somebody's not authentic
we often read it and we can tell so you
start out by taking the pulse as we've
talked about and then from that pulse
you create a vision you say here's what
i want to do here's what I want to
achieve and what I always caution people
is one step at a time if you're Hillary
Clinton and you're running for Senate
the first campaign but you know you
really want to run for president you
don't talk about well I'm running for
Senate so it will be a stepping stone
for my presidential campaign you people
want you to do one step at a time they
don't want you to go from necessarily
mirror to president they want you to be
governor in between so you define your
vision and maybe an interim vision if
your senator Clinton for example or
Secretary Clinton you define your vision
and then you create a set of materials
towards getting there if you're in the
kind of job that needs a press kit it
may be a press kit it may be a website
it may be your photography on it may be
your Facebook page but what's really
important is that if people meet you in
person if they see you if they go to
your Facebook page if they go to your
website if they look at your press kit
that everything is a cohesive whole that
they're all taking you in the same place
and even to the point of how you dress
and I go into a lot more nuanced things
in the book on how to handle crisis and
how to do interviews but the real the
real basic steps are defined where you
want to be and create the materials that
are going to help you get there and then
and then we create the initiatives or
what I call them the publicize abaut
moments that are going to call attention
what it is you're trying to achieve some
simple doesn't it